BUILDING.
TELUS FLAMES HOCKEY IS UNDER WAY
FROM
MANGIAPANE STOPPED BY LEHNER.
GOT THE PAD ON THAT CHANCE.
PLAYED BACK TTION.
JUST MISSES.
THEN THE FLAMES CONTINUE TO WORK
SCORES!
[Horn sounds]
THE HIGH MAN.
AND PIETRANGELO WENT TO HIM.
THINKING THAT THERE'S A
GAUDREAU W
RIGHT BACK IN FRONT.
McNABB CAN'T GET A SHOT
HELPS OUT JACOB MARKSTRO
MAY HAVE GONE OFF THE
THAT MUCH EASY ICE.
IT IS HARD TO STOPS THAT SIDE O
GOAL.
EASY PLAY BY LEHN
REFEREE FREDERIKE TO TKACHUK.
IN FRONT TO LINDHOLM.
AND LEHNER FORCED
THAT'S AT LEAST TWO.
THAT'S THREE.
AND RIGHT TAPE TO
KYLINGTON.
KEPT ONSIDE BY HAGUE.
HAGUE LOOKS IN FRONT.
GREAT SA RIGHT TO NOLAN PATRICK.
AND HE TRIED TO GO FIVE
BACKLUND THREW IT IN FRONT.
THEY SCORE!
MANGIAPANE PUTS IT HOME
AND ALL OF A SUDcNABB.
BIG ONE ON PIETRANGELO.
THEN LASTLY
HERE'S PATRICK!
AND THAT GOES HIGH!
WATCH HIM BLOCKER JUST GETS A
PIECE AT THE VERY LAST SECOND.
WAY.
SLOWS IT
RICK, IS A VERY IMPORTANT
[Horn sounds]
>> RicF LEHNER's
THERE.
RIGHT?
THERE IT IS.
AND ABLE TO GET THATRKSTROM SAVE
TERRIFIC ANTICIPATION BY
MARKSTROM.
NOW HE GOES BACK TO WORK. DID.
>> Kelly: SURE HAS.
>> Rick: PACIORETTY IN KNEE H.
PUCK STILL LOOSE.
SOMEHOW, ANOTHER CHANCE,
MANGIAly: WELL I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO  BA
LEHNER.
BACKLUND LOOKING FOR HIS FOURTH
POINT.
THAT WOULD BE T FOR
MIKAEL BACKLUND.
ON TO THE STICK OF MANGIAPANE.